I literally did not know if I was going
to live to see the morning the last five
months in pre unstable Yemen since the
Arab Spring it's been pretty unstable
but people are allowed to function the
ports work the airport's work people can
move freely for me that what happened
was the turning point it was on March 27
I was at at the milk a coffee mill
working late night and I decided to
sleep over there spend the night there
at two thirty or so in the morning I
woke up too loud explosions all around
me so I went outside I looked up in the
sky and I what I could see was like
laser beams being shot in the sky and
those were anti-aircraft machine gun
fire and so I found out that Saudi Jets
were flying over Yemen capital and
bombing it's a lot and it was just it
felt like Armageddon I literally did not
know if I was gonna live to see the
morning what played out over the next
days and now weeks and what was the mood
of people on the ground there it was
just a blitzkrieg was shocked we didn't
know we didn't expect it at all I was
unexpected and so in the morning I woke
up and I decide okay I need to get a
plane the first plane get out of here
and two things calm down and they
enacted a no-fly zone and they stopped
all naval activity in Yemen outside
Yemen and around it so we were trapped
nothing nowhere to go and throughout all
of this are you trying to contact the
American consulate or embassy I mean
what was the communication you had with
your country so initially you know we
contact the US Embassy when i say we i
say mean a thousands of other Yemeni
Americans stuck there and this we got
the same responses there are currently
no evacuation plans for Yemenis American
citizens what we could do for you is we
can relay your messages to your loved
ones on our website for me that I the
thought of telling my mother and father
that I'm terrified I might die I don't
want them to know that what really hurt
me even worse was that other countries
so China Russia India Pakistan djibouti
Somalia these countries were all
evacuating their citizens even as we
speak now when you consider the fact to
that the United States
is providing support to the coalition
that is then bombing Yemen I mean how
conflicted were you on the ground as a
Yemeni American it was a sad reality
we're not getting it be evacuated the
same time our countries provide
logistical support for these bombings or
really Ella hurt me was about seven or
eight days ago a Saudi plane fighter jet
malfunction across the Red Sea and to
play pilots a jacket ejected out and the
US Navy I was there save those two
pilots these Saudi pilots and so I knew
there was three US ships there and it's
just uh yeah and it was just a film a
feel of being abandoned by your own
country why do you think they abandoned
you that's a good question you ask them
we even asked them since I got here and
have had a reply for a lot of Americans
they either don't know where Yemen is or
if they do know anything about Yemen
they think it's this haven for
terrorists or al-qaeda in the Arabian
Peninsula is based there what should
Americans know about about Yemen and
they have many people I think Stephen
Colbert said this one time Yemenis on
are your enemies and I love that quote
when I ask people what do you think
about Yemen it's the same thing you said
but if you go and you see these pictures
that I have on my website or just google
Yemen it looks amazing beautiful green
lush valleys and mountain terraces
beautiful people smiling some of the
most hospitable people who ever meet
wonderful foods you have somehow which
is considered one probably one of the
oldest continuously inhabited cities in
the world a lot of ancient trade routes
I went through Yemen and through mocha
and these are things that I wish people
knew about Yemen